these are the required content provider
functions you can implement them any way
you like but you'll find that it's
really straightforward to implement them
on top of an SQLite database the
parameters passed into our content
provider functions match the parameters
used for androids
SQLite interface almost exactly the
biggest difference is that we replace
the table string with a URI in the
simplest content provider implementation
the query is passed straight through to
the database note that there are
parameters that cannot be easily
controlled through content providers
such as grouping functionality but the
interface allows for very flexible
querying most importantly the projection
or columns allows for querying to be
much more efficient because the column
indices in our cursor object matched the
projection that we submit to the
database we can just get the values by
their numerical index instead of having
to use get column index to look up each
column index all right it's time to code
some more sunshine let's code a content
provider